hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba what's
your name I'm adorable Rachel adorable
rachel is her birth giving Christian
name glad to have you back here today
Rachel we are going to watch today try
not to laugh challenge it continues
that's right reaction videos all across
the world are doing this and I've
successfully been doing it once a week
and it's gonna be a challenge for me
because I I sock it try not to laugh
challenges I've always failed them but
I'm not a huge Family Guy fan so I'm
interested to see in if this will make
me laugh at all so I hope that upsets
people
on that note hey Rachel why don't you
tell them about that Kickstarter thing
you were telling me about sure I am
working for a company called Suazo
I puppeteer with them for those who
don't know I'm a puppeteer in my
day-to-day life right now they have a
Kickstarter going on where they are
going to produce a children's book for
next Christmas it's called Merry
Christmas Krampus and as a lot of you
may or may not know Krampus is a
folklore character from Europe who
brings coal to the kids so it's a lovely
children's book based on that so if you
guys want to contribute to the
Kickstarter please go ahead and follow
the links in the description down below
wherever they may put them and it's
going on to the very end of December so
please contribute it's gonna be a really
fun mm-hmm all pledged $1 thank you
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they ride the heat of these things it's
a find a good position to sit on the
ground yeah cool I got that blanket from
your trunk
oh yeah yo scratchy trunk blanket bring
it use it once then put it back in the
truck for the rest of your life yeah
okay but it's my sitting on my knees on
the palms until they get weird he's
upstairs in his room good idea I better
check out my hairless twin in the storm
[ __ ] it's almost Christmas it's almost
Christmas Christmas yes
be it good and all the eggshells and
coffee grounds family let's eat all the
garbage we want
hey guys hairless what is heavier yeah
sorry I struck out looking I'm sorry
it's not funny
you're fighting I can tell I mean yeah I
was just in New Orleans I got it
don't look so mad I'll just do what
Superman ties he was just here no I'm
here because I've got important news
Lois everyone I'd left your mother and
Tricia Takanawa is moving in with me
holy crap what I wanted you to know I
never loved well good for you for being
honest Kenna it's never good to keep
something that matters to you a secret
tell her about the surf camp in Belize
Peter tell me you're going
tell her it's your dream and you deserve
it it'll make you a better father
what's that Peter nothing just some
stupid
[Applause]
I office morning it's not like we're
short on dough that's the concern this
money is our ticket to the good life
starting now
I just bought a giant room full of gold
coins and I'm gonna die oh god the Bonin
away
I love this song I love this song - you
and me both
I have given this a lot of thought I
need you to shoot me in the arm so we
can be friends again
okay and then you were supposed to say
no Peter I'm not gonna shoot you
oh I do appreciate the gesture hand me
the gun Peter hey Mel Peter I'm gonna
shoot you like a dirty animal the only
thing that means anything to me is a
[Music]
[Music]
look at that there I finally laugh at
the very end Rachel went through her
character art did you guys see that she
started off with I don't really know I
feel about this went into I'm not for
that she was all Scrooge McGrew about
the whole thing
I will admit there were a few parts in
there where I could have laughed but not
enough to like make me burst out and
like me really like I was able to resist
like there was a few good for you oh
good for you there's a few little
moments in there I just you know what I
don't mind offensive humor
and I know it can be funny but I just
don't find Family Guy that clever most
of the time hey
comedy is objective it's very objective
yes it's not entitled to personal
opinion okay it is universally hilarious
and everyone finds this equally
hilarious so get that stick out of your
ass and get on the objective train my
ass is beautiful no comic or no stick
tweet I mean that was a challenge I'm
amazed that I actually survived that
yes survive is the word to use their
intents of a challenge I know the family
got bits always making me laugh I really
like the long going bits which it seemed
like you are not a fan no I love the
like the one with the whole planning the
heist and the ridiculous scenarios about
it that [ __ ] cracks me up so much I mean
it just went on forever I could see like
maybe four or five of those but he like
they went on with like ten of them and
it was just it got boring after a while
it was like I don't know there's a part
of me that's like okay I got the joke
can we move on now because like I feel
like I know but I don't find it funny
that one joke that I think that I was
was kind of clever but again I was
annoyed by was the one with Stewie on
the blanket yeah yeah like I get it but
I feel like I can also just smell a
forced joke from like a mile away and
that just I just felt so for just like I
get the joke but it just it was insanely
for it's the way that it was presented
and put this I get it you know comedy is
objective no comedy is very subjective
if I see a comedy movie that has an
insanely low rating on Rotten Tomatoes
that's it's like a comedy sometimes I
will agree and other times they'll be
like I thought this movie was hysterical
I like the movie wild wild west no one
else does I've never seen a movie but I
do really like scary movie 3 and that
has an insanely yeah I think that one's
funny too yeah I like scary movie 4 as
well I don't like 5 but I like 3 and 4
and both of those are not considered
good movies
the embassy there's a lot of stuff out
there I like that's not good yeah and I
think comedy is very subject and it's a
very yeah I feel like out of all genres
that especially is the water that's why
the extent of comics have a really hard
job because how do you create comedy
that's gonna make the whole world laugh
you know big big challenge so if it's
not for you I get it but with that in
mind that means you win Rachael gay 1000
quarters are coming your way
okay well I can do some laundry with
that I guess yeah yeah convert to a
thousand quarters that would be that
would be like what 200 something dollars
oh not bad huh $250 nevermind you're
getting 500 quarters too much you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check out
adorable Rachel on the adorable Rachel
YouTube channel and also that
Kickstarter the Merry Christmas Krampus
book go check it out